all these years you thought you knew
which character was the real antagonist
of the craft but by the end of this
video you'll never see the movie the
same way again
the craft wastes no time in introducing
us to its principal characters the film
opens on three young witches nancy
richelle and bonnie performing a pagan
ceremony after a flashy opening credits
sequence we meet protagonist sarah
bailey a san francisco transplant who's
recently moved to los angeles with her
father sarah's first day in her new la
home takes a frightening turn when a
strange man holding a huge snake walks
right through her front door and
presents it to her as some kind of
twisted housewarming present this
doesn't seem to leave sarah too
traumatized to start at her new catholic
school the following day despite the
fact that she's yet to be fitted for a
uniform elsewhere at school bonnie's
astrological readings predict the
arrival of a newcomer whom she
interprets as being the fourth member
she and her friends need to complete
their circle a sentiment that nancy
wholeheartedly disagrees with when
bonnie sees sarah performing telekinesis
with a pencil in french class she knows
exactly who her reading was referring to
despite bonnie's eagerness to induct
sarah into their coven nancy scares
sarah away with a wordless glare when
she asks the trio if she can join their
lab group sitting alone at lunch sarah
is joined by popular jaw chris hooker
who welcomes her to the school when she
points out the girls that snubbed her in
biology chris calls them an offensive
name and warns sarah to stay away
because they're infamous for being
witches even though sarah is initially
doubtful she finds herself intrigued by
both chris and the girls
after school sarah is watching chris at
football practice when she's approached
by nancy richelle and bonnie noticing
sarah's interest in the team captain
nancy gives her a stern warning sarah
isn't sure what to think but when the
girls invite her to go shopping with
them she finds herself compelled to join
on their walk to the local occult store
nancy notices scars on sarah's wrists
sarah confesses that her family's
relocation was spurred by an attempt she
made on her own life back in san
francisco the responses from the girls
are less than compassionate to say the
least the occult shop run by the
enigmatic proprietor lyrio is filled
with all kinds of esoteric iconography
just as sarah is about to open the
curtain to a hidden back room lyrio
stops her and gives her a quick reading
the shop owner recognizes that sarah's
ring previously belonged to her late
mother and tells the girl she has
natural powers but sarah takes this with
a grain of salt on their way home the
same man who'd accosted sarah with a
snake sees and chases her again only to
be run over by a passing car collecting
their thoughts after the accident the
group comes to the conclusion that their
individual wishes for the man to stop
willed the passing car into hitting him
when nancy starts explaining manol the
deity the girls worship sarah knows for
sure that her new friends aren't playing
around sarah admits that magical things
seem to happen to her all the time but
she gets frightened by nancy's intensity
and excuses herself
after her whirlwind evening with saint
benedict's resident witches sarah tries
to take her mind off things by agreeing
to go out with chris hooker they have a
good time but when she refuses to go
back to his house chris decides to
spread a vile rumor around school that
they'd actually hooked up and that it
hadn't gone well she tries to confront
chris in the hallway but only ends up
getting humiliated even further in the
meantime sarah's new friends are all
dealing with personal problems of their
own as one of the only black students at
st benedict's rochelle has to put up
with constant tormenting from a racist
bully named laura and her gaggle of
followers bonnie has burn scars all over
her shoulders and back from a childhood
accident and is undergoing extremely
painful experimental gene therapy to try
and remove them nancy lives in a rundown
trailer with her alcoholic mother grace
and her abusive stepfather ray the next
day the three invite sarah on a field
trip which she accepts and the group
takes a bus out to the desolate woods
deep in the woods sarah rochelle nancy
and bonnie begin a ceremony that
officially establishes their circle they
hold each other at knife point while
reciting an incantation the four witches
then pierce their index fingers and mix
their blood with wine performing their
first group spell they each drink in
turn asking meno for what their hearts
desire rochelle wants revenge on laura
sarah wants chris to return her
affections and bonnie wants to be
beautiful on the outside as well as him
nancy however dreams a little bit bigger
within a matter of hours sarah's love
spell on chris begins working and she
manipulates his new obsession to
humiliate him in retaliation the coven
decides to further test their abilities
by playing light as a feather stiff as a
board the result of which undoubtedly
confirms the presence of supernatural
intervention the next day when laura
bullies rochelle her signature blonde
quaff immediately starts falling out
then at her next doctor's appointment
bonnie's scars melt off her body with
impossible ease leaving the doctor
speechless the magic is working
for everyone but nancy that is
frustrated by manol's lack of
intervention until now nancy returns to
her dysfunctional family but a violent
encounter that ends in her stepfather
dying of a heart attack seems to prove
that her prayers have not been ignored
after all a life insurance policy leaves
nancy and her mother
175 000
which they used to move into fancier
digs downtown at nancy's new apartment
the witches practice glamouring a type
of spell that can change outward
appearances with just a bit of
concentration all is not well in the
witches world however sarah's love spell
seems to have been too effective turning
chris's newfound desire into a dangerous
obsession sarah consults lyrio for
advice on how to break the spell but she
learns an unfortunate truth about
witchcraft a spell must run its course
she also learns about the law of karmic
justice at the beach at twilight the
coven arrives with their familiars as
they prepare to invoke the spirit of men
here sarah opens up some more about her
past specifically that she used to
hallucinate snakes and insects around
the time of her suicide attempt unfazed
nancy leads an incredibly intense
ceremony that provokes lightning and
wind as the women chant the next morning
they awaken on the beach to find nancy
walking on water and a horde of dead
sharks washed ashore
sarah understandably freaked out by the
invocation ceremony tries to talk sense
into the other three witches but they're
all drunk on nancy's power even though
rochelle experiences some remorse when
she sees laura having a panic attack
over her balding scalp it's three
against one and nancy is starting to
think that maybe sarah shouldn't be part
of the coven after all feeling lost and
afraid sarah turns to chris for support
even though his obsession is reaching
dangerous levels she agrees to go out
with him for dinner but instead chris
takes her to a remote spot where he
sexually assaults her sarah manages to
escape to rochelle's house and tells the
other witches what happened and in a fit
of rage nancy lures chris upstairs at a
nearby party and glamours herself into
sarah when the real sarah breaks the
glamour and chris is dismissive once
again nancy loses it she throws chris
out a window with her mind killing him
instantly
in the wake of chris's death which
everyone conveniently thinks was an
accident sarah breaks with the coven
entirely she cuts nancy out of a group
photo and attempts to do a binding spell
that would prevent nancy from hurting
anyone else or herself unfortunately for
sarah the power of meno has given nancy
the ability to read her mind and torment
her with terrible dreams and
hallucinations at school nancy bonnie
and rochelle accost sarah in the
bathroom telling her that they were all
interviewed by police following chris's
death nancy argues that rey and chris
deserve to die and if sarah wants to
leave the coven she'd better watch her
back desperate sarah gosselin at the
occult shop for help and explains her
predicament lyrio invites sarah into the
secret back room a pagan temple built on
a place of power she lights all the
candles with one match and tells sarah
she's from a long line of witches and
needs to invoke manol herself before
illyrio can help any further however
nancy disrupts the ceremony astrally
forcing sarah to retreat home
sarah arrives at an empty house and
finds out that her father and stepmother
flew to san francisco thinking that
sarah had run away unbelievably their
plane crashed killing everyone on board
just when sarah thinks things couldn't
get any worse the house starts filling
with snakes bugs rats and all sorts of
creepy crawlies the creatures chase
sarah until she's face to face with
nancy who reveals that the whole thing
was a glamour and that she's planning on
staging sarah's suicide desperate to
fight back sarah is forced to invoke the
spirit of manol herself in the process
she gives bonnie and rochelle a taste of
their own medicine with the law of karma
and the two run away in fear sarah
finishes invoking the spirit and uses
the opportunity to torment nazi the same
way she tormented her using all sorts of
glamours and tricky spells nancy tries
to kill sarah but with her newly invoked
powers sarah is able to successfully
bind nancy and end their showdown for
good days later bonnie and rochelle
visit sarah to apologize for their
actions during the confrontation they
reveal they've lost their powers but
that doesn't stop sarah from using her
abilities to try and crush them with a
tree branch finally the craft ends with
nancy in a mental institution shouting
about the power of manol as she's being
restrained and sedated
while the craft is framed as a movie
about four young witches with new girl
sarah bailey at center over the years
the discourse surrounding the film has
deepened considerably to propose the
notion that sarah might in fact be the
bad guy here for one sarah abandons her
sisters on several occasions to run back
to chris hooker the guy who spread a
nasty rumor about her right at the start
even after chris tries to sexually
assault sarah and nancy kills him in
retaliation sarah still tries to defend
him
say what by the end of the craft when
sarah has invoked the spirit of menol
instead of trying to help the nancy with
her newfound powers she taunts her with
the same manipulations that nancy used
on her effectively driving her mad by
the film's end she also ends the film by
threatening bonnie and rochelle even
after they confessed to losing their
powers it seems as if sarah took her
powers to as dark a place as nancy's
went but for whatever reason she's
allowed to get away with it
if sarah is the actual villain of the
craft then we need to reassess her foil
nancy downs nancy starts the film living
in a trailer park where her stepdad
regularly abuses her alcoholic mother
their electricity is often out since
they can't pay their bills and there's
even a hole in the roof over nancy's bed
tripping water on her face as she tries
to sleep the implication is that nancy
is a scholarship student at the elite st
benedict's catholic school and that she
spends her free time casting spells to
try and lift her and her mother out of
poverty on top of all that nancy was
given an std and abandoned by chris
hooker not to mention how often rey
seems to violate her bodily autonomy the
link between poverty a lack of health
care and possible underlying mental
illness combined with dabbling in the
occult was a devastating cocktail for
nancy she wanted the power to change her
life and circumstances but she didn't
know how to do it without using
supernatural means even when she and her
mom came into a considerable amount of
money nancy still isn't able to address
her root traumas
that said the craft has a far more
ambiguous ending than people think
thanks to sarah's spell nancy is only
bound against hurting herself and others
not against using magic as a whole if
she'd been able to gather her thoughts
and regroup internally she could realize
that she still has access to menaul's
power this could change her
circumstances for the better once again
even without violence furthermore a
spell only lasts as long as the witch
who cast it lives so if sarah dies
before nancy nancy could be walking on
water again in no time
on the surface the craft is a story
about young women coming into personal
and collective power through magic
however this camaraderie only lasts
briefly and it's not long before the
four women involved all turn on each
other in vicious ways first nancy's
ongoing jealousy of sarah's natural
powers turns into a disaster as sarah
tries to guide the group's growing magic
down which she considers healthier paths
as the divide between nancy and sarah
grows bonnie and rachelle choose the
side of power and stick with nancy even
as she becomes increasingly erratic and
violent once sarah has had enough the
other three mercilessly bully her just
as they've been tormented by others
culminating in a truly grotesque plan to
kill sarah and stage it as a suicide
nancy exploits vulnerable information
about sarah's suicide attempt
information that was told her in
confidence to further torture her even
after sarah helps wake bonnie and
rochelle up to their bad behavior they
still only apologize because they've
lost their powers and want them back the
craft ends with sarah cutting off
rochelle and bonnie while poor nancy is
locked up in a mental institution if it
isn't already obvious the craft is more
about fraught and toxic relationships
between women than female friends who
actually empower each other if you or
anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts please call the national
suicide prevention lifeline at
1-800-273-talk
that's 1-800-273-8255
[Music]